putting bags over women's heads you're
actually putting a bag over a chick's
head but I'm the bad guy hey guys I'm
off the grid for August but my friend
billmar probably maybe said something
that kind of made sense but also didn't
make sense and I'm working on you Bill
come on man you'll get there it's
Taliban are not big on girls Schools
they're not big on girls getting
educated
and how liberals
liberals can be on the wrong side of
this issue it's the biggest mind boggler
for me like how you can somehow when I
criticize
traditional Muslim societies for the way
they engage in what you have to call
gender apartheid putting bags over
women's heads you're actually putting a
bag over a chick's head but I'm the bad
guy because I'm pointing this out you're
the liberal and you're on the other side
of this issue really because that's
islamophobic or whatever word
you want to call it uh really I'm not
the okay
that's when I knew they had lost their
way when they got that issue wrong after
9 11. that's when that's when it okay
things have switched up now foreign